- [David] Hello readers.
Today we're going to be talking
about how smaller sections
of text work together
to support the whole text.
But first let us consider Voltron.
It is a giant robot made
up of five smaller robots,
each one piloted by a person.
Five friends, each with control
over a different part of the robot's body.
You're up in the head, I'm
operating the right leg,
our buddy's operating the left, and so on.
In order to walk or pick up objects
or fight space monsters
the size of battleships,
all the disparate of the robot
have to function together.
Well, texts work much the same way.
Each portion of the text,
from the section level down
to more granular divisions
like individual paragraphs or sentences,
is trying to serve the
broader point of the text.
When we look at Voltron's foot in motion,
we analyze what the foot is doing
in the service of Voltron as a whole.
If Voltron's foot kicks a ball,
we have to zoom out to ask,
is Voltron playing soccer?
This is a pretty abstract idea
without any text examples,
so let's stop talking about space robots
and start talking about the Armor
of 10th-century Japanese horse archers.
All right, so this whole
passage is about the armor
worn by mounted archer
samurai of 10th-century Japan,
o-yoroi, and how it's constructed.
So this is a piece of o-yoroi armor.
This is the whole assemblage.
And that's how the
piece is divided, right?
We've got the sections
here for each component.
The cuirass, the o-sode
or shoulder guards,
the kusazuri, or armored skirt,
and the kabuto, the helmet.
And each one of these
elements of the armor
connects back to the
whole point of the piece,
which is describing how
the armor does two things.
One, it protects the wearer, and two,
allows them to ride
horses and fire arrows.
Now we see this in the
introductory paragraph.
Their armor, called o-yoroi,
was designed specifically
to withstand the demands
of mounted archer warfare.
So let's dig into this first
section about the cuirass,
the breastplate and backplate armor.
I'll read the first paragraph.
"A cuirass is usually a piece of armor
"that consists of a
breastplate and a backplate
"that are attached together.
"The cuirass for the
o-yoroi was a bit different
"than a typical cuirass,
"as it was designed to be
more effective for an archer.
"The o-yoroi cuirass had
three sections instead of two.
"A section to protect the back,
"a section to protect the chest,
"and a section to protect
the left side body.
"The right side was left open
"so the warrior could best
utilize his bow and arrow."
So this paragraph is
describing what a cuirass is
and how it functions as armor,
but then it goes into detailing
how an o-yoroi cuirass is different
because it's for someone
holding a bow, right?
It has three sections instead of two.
The right side was left
open so the warrior
could best utilize his bow and arrow.
This information down
to the sentence level
all serves the same purpose.
It serves to answer the question,
how was o-yoroi armor
specifically designed
to meet the needs of a mounted archer?
Not every sentence or every paragraph
will address every part
of that main question.
Note that the cuirass
section doesn't cover
anything about how the
archers are on horseback.
To answer that question,
we need to go down to the third section,
the kusazuri, the battle skirt.
I'm not gonna read the whole paragraph.
Let's just zoom in on this one sentence.
"The kusazuri were designed
so that when the warrior
"was sitting in his horse's saddle,
"they fit nicely over the
saddle in a skirtlike fashion
"to protect his lower
body and upper legs."
This particular sentence tells us
how this part of the armor
protects the samurai's legs
while they're on horseback.
The paragraph and section it's part of
detail the whole construction
of that part of the armor
and how it relates to the other pieces.
And all of those paragraphs
together form one text
that explained the thing
it set out to explain.
What is o-yoroi and how does it work
for 10th-century horse archer samurai?
Each section or paragraph is like a leg
or an arm of Voltron.
Each sentence is a muscle
or a finger or a robo-toe.
Together, moving as one, they tell a story
or make an argument, which
I guess is like Voltron
winning a fight, maybe.
I feel like I've carried this
metaphor as far as it'll go.
The point is, if you're having trouble
making sense of an informational text,
think of it as a giant battle robot.
What is each of component part of the text
trying to accomplish?
And when you put all those parts together,
what are they trying to do?
Well, my work here is done.
You can learn anything.
David out.